je savais que j'avais rendez vous avec
sharon stone
ça me fait plaisir toi tu veux ta jupe
qui sait parler aux femmes à travers
quand tu vas ma chérie ravi d'accepter
ce petit à petit rat d'égout
[Musique]
je voulais faire un petit compliment
j'aime bien cueillir les gens achats
d'or alors découvrir les hommes avec un
petit compliment entre nous cher patrick
louis ne s'est rien passé et l'os et
contenant 20 ans qu'est ce que j'ai
essayé le procès et si on s'y mettait
pourquoi pas car je sens que je roule
alors approché vous mais ça suce pas ces
changements oui c'est l'arrivée j'ai pas
pour veiller à ce qu est ce qu en fait
patrick on a quand même une longue
histoire à chaque fois qu'on se croise
je te dis je désirais pas né je te dis
voilà si ça peut rendre service
ça serait pas pour rendre service à
certains plaisirs bien en parlant de rim
je reçois quand même l'auteur de talent
parce que franchement entre nous cet
album il est magnifique ce gentil sa
place entre nous et ces voix là c'est
une vraie patrie se déroule sur moi je
suis sûr et à l'oreille adhésion non il
y en a plus que ça tout m'intéresse plus
c'est qu'à la foulée chez denisot
au cap d'agde deux secondes c'est votre
vrai voix et franchement elle fait du
bien cette voie j'espère qu'elle fait
les messages aussi est par exemple le tu
verras quand j'étais au bord de l'eau on
va on était des caméras situées année et
sinon pour continuer à tour deux
confrères ça va valoir polio fausse
sextape une sextape de traction peut
aller se rhabiller c'est le moment de
dire qu'ils ont déjà prévu des sextoys
la balle je me retiens c'est une
bouteille de champagne
c'est pendant son show avec je vais
aussi continuer chez le sexe pour les
choses qui après qu'on l'ait nul
j'ai trouvé que dans cet album il ya une
fois la tendresse de bourvil et puis le
franc-parler de coluche j'ai envie de
faire un petit hinder avec par exemple
coluche coliche et heureuse issue s'est
pas trompé mais dans le cul ça compense
fois c'est des phrases de base ouais
c'était un cd truc tu fais que ce tueur
si tu coupes la caméra je peux te faire
voir sess détruits et bienvenue au resto
de la [ __ ] à à défaut des restos du
coeur
il était comme ça gros seins aujourd'hui
c'est des gros mots comme il disait même
si c'est une petite [ __ ] séquence gros
bond ville comment ils auraient comment
ils aborder les femmes à ton avis le
problème
oui chacun sait jamais ce clip de
demande forcément beaucoup moins bien
marché ça c'est de répliques ordures où
tu sais que tu sais que c'est une team
qui me fait marrer avec saint faustin
lac tchad raillé et qui me disait mais
moi l'artiste j'en ai rien à [ __ ] et
cetera je peux veut pas coucher avec un
mec parce qu'il est connu
elle m'a fait ça pendant trois plombes
tu vois est finalement assez retrouver
vouliez
et au moment où c'était en plein de
trucs me dit tu veux pas limité bourvil
et donc effectivement ça a baissé et
j'ai balancé bas forcément c'est du vécu
c'est du vrai wagon alors je me suis
fait plaisir romy patrick je demanderai
que votre vraie voix parce que sur
l'album entre nous c'est la vraie votre
patrie qu'ils aient les bords vous allez
découvrir quelque chose c'est
enveloppant la punition serait de rendre
coup pour coup mais la clémence et sache
et les bourreaux sont fous mais là je
pense qu'on va analyser un peu le matin
mise et c'est le moment de la lumière on
va vous allez me susurrer une chanson
m'est cher et c'est quand même ses
secrets mais là ils ont dû faire des
allusions ces fameux sony elle n'arrête
pas de faire des allusions vous allez me
suis sur une chanson dont j'ai tout fait
l'achat directement
[Musique]
et
bala m bala la seule celle qui m'énerve
c'est qu'il y ait des trucs pour mieux
apprécier un miroir bon je crois que
études étant occupés voilà je me suis
laissé aller mais c'est pas du tout je
suis un véritable romantique et s'il
devait y avoir une liaison entre nous en
resterons aux mots susurrés
mais tu vite à mettre les dents cause